good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday i am
claudia ashrae and i am pro-choice hi
claude how you doing i'm doing good i'm
doing good it's been a crazy couple of
days it's been a crazy couple of days
and i feel like a lot of people want to
hear from here what we have to say about
we are just lightning rods in our
industry we really are we're like female
icons and i do feel like you know moguls
sorry i misspoke i feel like if we don't
you know talk about the news of the
weekend that a lot of people will come
for our next yeah um like we find
ourselves in a difficult position we
actually had like an hour-long facetime
this morning about how we wanted to
tackle this because as you guys know our
policy here at the morning shows is like
we really we do not talk about politics
for a multitude of reasons but mostly
because like this show is everything of
the sort i think a lot of people rely on
the show just to kind of escape yeah
it's we're so funny i think
so talented that we really make people
forget about the trials and tribulations
of their everyday life and a part of
being just like a human being
in america right now with access to
social media it's like it's so
overwhelming and it's so taxing like
how inundated with information you are
and how like even like the influencer
culture of like
having to post forever like it's it's
extremely toxic i think yeah and it's
really bizarre the influencer culture
where it's like everybody posts the same
infographic that really isn't like
moving the needle or or saying much they
just like don't want to be
attacked yeah or like mark just like i
they think i think this or i didn't say
anything about that and it's not really
about caring about what's going on it's
just about like front facing and so if
someone you follow like hasn't posted it
never occurs to someone like maybe
they're processing maybe they're
figuring out how they feel maybe they're
talking to their local uh
representatives like or posting on
social media what an indication of how
you feel maybe they're not an expert on
the matter right so like it's it's a
very weird space we find ourselves in
and this weekend i think was really
emblematic of that because i think a lot
of people were internalizing the
information and like when it came out on
friday
it was very um alarming you know it was
like oh my god the world is ending and
when
when you actually like when you look
into what what's happening
it's a lot of information to take in
yeah and i think there's also a lot of
misinformation going around um but we
are very adamant about not talking about
politics on the show it gets harder and
harder every day because politics is
like worming its way into literally
every aspect of life but still we try
and stay the course and i feel so
strongly that there should be and there
can be people and spaces that are
politics-free agreed one because like we
don't want like politics is messy and
disgusting and this show is gorgeous
beautiful stunning and smart one
two
we don't ever like want to be divisive
you know and there's enough of that and
i feel just also very strongly
that we don't need to wait into politics
even if there's like pressure from
people you need to speak about this why
aren't you using your platform like if
you don't like how we use our platform
build your own platform you know
so i i feel very
certain yeah we don't need to speak
about but sometimes there are things or
events that aren't necessarily political
that you know tug at the heartstrings
have before that we do want to mention
um
but that's not the same that's not the
same no i just did feel like given the
rent i went on last week about the
government coming for my jewel yeah it
did feel particularly appropriate um
given like the next day that the
government i'm just i'm kind of feeling
like the more i delve into my own
political
beliefs i think i'm an anarchist like
[ __ ] the god like that's what i was
realizing because every time i'm like
government go away like i'm honestly i'm
an anti-government anarchist that's what
i realized like don't tell me what to
jewel don't tell me what to do with my
body like i that is the conclusion i've
come to today okay anarchy for life love
that for you so we wanted to mention it
but again like just reinforce the values
of the toaster like an inclusive space
where we just really try and keep it
light and that's not for everyone and
that's totally fine there are so many
shows you can listen to that are going
to scratch the itch that you're looking
for but here at the toast it's not
because our views are unpopular no we're
not where people think we're not ashamed
and it's not because i don't care about
politics or i don't care about these
things that are happening i've had so
many conversations over the weekend like
and in my personal life i have a lot of
thoughts and feelings
but there's very little room for nuance
in general and internet in the digital
space especially for us we get literally
nothing no leeway so we don't want to
have these
big conversations there and we don't
also don't want to just like serve up
platitudes and say and be disingenuous
right so i agree with you i think the
lack of nuance on the internet makes it
really difficult to have genuine and
meaningful conversations yeah um so
we're just going to talk about the
kardashians right and in a genuine and
meaningful way
with lots of nuance
and
don't forget about layers no it's true
it's extremely layered yeah so
happy monday i hope everyone had a great
weekend um you know i actually had a
nice weekend because i have like not
permanently but like i was like i'm not
drinking and it was
amazing like it was i see
the perks of sobriety i really do i felt
like the weekend was so long when i woke
up on sunday morning i was like oh my
god it's [ __ ] monday i'm like no
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i feel so like balanced i spent so
much time with you and harold i read so
much and i got my [ __ ] ass up and i
saw top gun finally i mean i'm so
jealous but also tell everyone you were
trying to see elvis and then you called
me and i was like you need to see top
guys me and ben were like let's go to
the movies and there was like so few
seats because the theater by us is
reserved seating which i do like um so
we had like limited options and the
better seats were for elvis and i was
like you know what i feel like i missed
the top gun moment anyway like
everyone's like yeah we saw [ __ ] a
month ago so now everyone's on their
like fourth viewing no now everyone's on
their elvis [ __ ] elvis came out this
weekend oh
so i was like ben let's see elvis and he
was like so mad and i'm like just shut
up
oh my god
i know i've been channeling
[ __ ] hrh energy it's anarchist
in me totally so i um
i called jackie and i was like by the
way we're seeing elvis not top gun just
to like you know have someone on my side
against ben and she was like
what are you doing you should see top
gun so we switched it the theater was
packed um and i
i want to be really cautious about what
i say because i don't know if you guys
know this but miles teller's iconic wife
kelly is a toaster and so the
possibility of um miles hearing my
review is almost 100
you know so this is what i want to say
i've i mean i've so many thoughts first
of all the movie was [ __ ] incredible
like do you think i give a [ __ ] about
planes no on that [ __ ] sea in the
theater i was like you [ __ ] playing
you better get in that [ __ ]
candy and yeah turn to the right turn to
the right two minutes and 30 seconds
[ __ ] yeah like i was being so plain
girly like literally the points girl
okay
it was so good so many hot [ __ ] men
but then it also made me realize it was
a lot of tom cruise and like i get it
it's like his franchise but it's like
it's time to pass the baton on to miles
teller and
glenn powell like
i literally did the weirdest thing this
weekend and i slid into glen powell's dm
what did you say well i like i like kind
of know glenn we've like actually been
on vacation together three times because
we have a mutual friend okay
how many people were on the vacation
just like 150. okay
but we've never um like we've spoken a
bunch like formalities we like follow
each other instagram but i love it for
you yeah i took the opportunity to slide
in because i thought he was incredible
he was so funny like his character was
hilarious he's so funny he's i've been
trying to tell you hot yeah oh my god so
i still didn't had like a nice
conversation with glenn taking our
relationship to the next level you know
um but it made me think about tom cruise
because tom cruise is like one of the
biggest movie stars in the world ready
yeah name one movie he's been in besides
top gun i was like i don't think i've
ever seen this man in a movie
uh
mission impossible jason statham no he's
mission impossible no he's top gun
no no there was only one top gun no and
like that's tom cruise like literally
what the [ __ ] is tom cruise been in i
think he's mission impossible yes he
says yes yeah okay okay fine that tracks
then okay yeah but yeah you're not tom's
target audience no so it was like a lot
of tom you're being introduced to tom
cruise for the first time an
up-and-coming actor i was and i think
this movie did a really good job of
telling you what happened in the first
there was like a couple flashbacks but
they explained because there were
characters from the old movie in the new
one um i don't think you need to see the
first one like if you want to you can
but it wasn't required viewing it was
just incredible miles was so good like
it was so amazing and i had heard this
song on tick tock a couple times but i
didn't really put together that lady
gaga had written a song for the movie is
that what the song is
i love that [ __ ]
it's so so good don't you let go of my
hand
[Music]
i've been listening to it over and over
again i'm like why is no one talking
about lady gaga's new song out but i
guess because it was for a movie and not
like a single on an album so we're not
like in album mode but they play it at
the end and it's like it's literally
like i had tears it was so good i
literally loved that song now the movie
had one thing that i didn't like and i
know this is going to make me sound like
a woman who doesn't support other women
women because there was literally one
woman in the movie but she happens to be
one of my least favorite actresses of
all time jennifer connelly okay and i
think it's because she's constantly
being cast in roles that like have her
as like the most annoying [ __ ] [ __ ]
on the planet like yeah when i think of
jennifer connelly i think of her as the
nagging wife and he's just not that into
you
it's a girl like get some scruples like
have a spine your husband's being a dick
um
so that was just like my personal she's
just not my favorite but she was the
only woman in the movie so like i hate
to be that girl like only saying like
the woman she was good was it her or her
character or both a little combo book
but i will say she's but
that's on them for making the female
character unlikable she wasn't unlikable
she just wasn't like
everything
yeah but i will say like i
people talk about like actresses who are
aging beautifully like gwyneth paltrow
jennifer connolly's up there like she
looked amazing okay also the movie was
set i think in san diego it was just
like stunning san diego's like
has it going on la jolla like you will
find me in la jolla okay
okay it and at legoland and at bell i'm
literally kris jenner like obsessed with
san diego i went once and i thought it
was like the most beautiful place on the
planet no the more i see of san diego
the more i'm like that's where it's at
i'm interested i'm very interested in
san diego so i really recommend the
movie even if you think it's not your
genre type like obviously i've never
seen an action movie in my life and i
couldn't get enough of the action it was
so well done and you know that's like
tom cruise's thing he is the stunt man
he does his own stunts and all the other
guys who are in the film like were doing
their own stunts too he raised the bar
he raised the bar i do feel like a
little icky about tom cruise just in
general like yeah especially because i
follow leah remini on tick tock and
she's like always coming for him and
she's totally right so like that was
like kind of the one
about the movie
but i do hope they make more top guns
and like you know miles is the new oh
wait i'm sorry maverick maverick it's
his name maverick that's okay so no it's
too much so tom cruise isn't it too much
tom cruise's name is maverick they all
have like first and last names but in
this special unit that they're in the
top gun unit
they all have nicknames so there's
rooster which is miles teller oh i'm
sorry i thought miles teller was
maverick
tom cruise's maverick over the edge
glenn powell was like hangman or
something and they all have like cool
quirky names that's so cute it was cute
and quirky and cute okay well i'm so
jealous i really want to see it if
anyone has a screen or is a member of
like the sag and can just get me a
screener oh my god by the way like why
didn't we just like ask kelly i know
well i hate to like ask for favors but
like if you or someone you know um gets
screeners or has a plane
i would like both yeah i think that's
fair to ask yeah i really do want to see
elvis though the reviews are coming in
we could ask for a screener yeah yeah
buzz if you're listening i just like
cannot get my ass out of my house
because like honestly even at the
theaters well first of all i was sitting
next to a guy who was so weird he was
just watch what you said
that's not what i'm saying
he came um
he came by himself which i was like okay
but he was the biggest top gun fan in
[ __ ] history first lady was talking
to himself the whole time which actually
did not bother me um because he was
having so much money he's like oh yeah
that [ __ ] plane is sick he was like
cursing he was like oh this is [ __ ]
awesome where did you give him a sweater
jar and by the way what's the top gun
song ha way to
the
danger zone he was singing it like he
was this was like really the best night
of his life so i wasn't gonna be like
annoying like karen like can you quiet
down but the theater was packed in the
first row it was like 16 year olds who
had like obviously gotten high and like
went to the movies and were cracking up
and running out of the theater every
five seconds and like
i guess i really am officially grown up
because i was in the part of the section
of the theater with everyone who was
like so [ __ ] annoyed like yeah some
guy actually said something to them and
like if that was me when i was 16 i
would be like oh these [ __ ] loser old
people but it's like no [ __ ] shut up
and sit down or leave yeah like i was
actually about to go get the manager
like that's how carrie and i was feeling
wow they were being so annoying it was a
group of like ten that's so teenage boys
hysterically laughing whispering getting
up every five seconds up down up down up
down and they're in the first row so
everyone could see that what were they
doing when they were getting up like
getting snatched i think they were like
getting snacks and they were also like
excusing themselves because they
couldn't stop laughing because they were
high and like
normally i think things like that like
make me feel nostalgic for my youth but
it just made me feel like i'm so glad
i'm not a [ __ ] teenager anymore we're
annoying and smelly and ugly
okay teenagers are ugly she said what
she said
and she meant it good you have to say i
know i i really really want to yeah and
i need to see all this like yeah
i was like even when i was really
enjoying the movie i was like i wonder
what's going on in the theater they were
playing at the same time like i wonder
what the people in elvis are doing you
know yeah maybe
elvis is like a little bit more elevated
perhaps there wouldn't have been
teenagers no there wouldn't have been
and you know me like if the movie's over
40 minutes like i can't watch it it was
two hours and 20 minutes flew by look at
you so good like i know i'm the last
person on the planet but like right you
got to see top guns people didn't need
to be convinced but i do think people
come here for your critical takes and
the thing is you are pretty critical
like you just walked out of dr of
enhanced in the movie like okay that's
by the way that's not critical no
but you
like you don't just like or love
anything no i worked out of the revenant
if you're loving something yeah it's
worth taking notes i've walked out of
bus i think this top gun movie is going
to be huge huge i walked out of boss
baby too oh i didn't see two but i liked
one me too enough to see two in theaters
i walked out of the revenant i walked
out of dear evan hansen i've walked out
of like probably like 19 out of 20 of
the last movies i've seen damn but
that's always not like a testament to
the movie more so to like my frame of
mind and also my circumstances like if
the chair is not comfortable the theater
i went to doesn't have fountain soda
they offer bottles i'm like what is this
1972.
no and they have a [ __ ] one of those
big ass vending machines with the touch
screen it's been broken like since
before covered i'm like curly get it
together the movie industry is back baby
like let's go yeah thanks to top gun
literally it was so good and like miles
teller's just everything and i ran to
the bathroom for like 10 seconds and it
was like one of those peas like you
don't even wash your hands you just go
so fast um and it made me think about
that's the thing nobody watches their
hands when they go to the theaters and
co-pay that's the thing
wait
like
i can't think of a place where you need
to wash your hands more of course but
you're missing then you're going to go
back to your like like this
i didn't eat i had dinner before oh look
at you i went to patsy's yum
so i didn't eat first of all but i
thought that was like a thing we were
all doing like not washing our hands at
the theater because like we want to run
back to them like i when i wake up in
the middle of the night to be i wash my
hands like so if i'm not watching my
hands at the movie theater that's
[ __ ] unhinged no like now because i
don't wake up in the middle of the night
a lot to be maybe by the end of my
pregnancy when i was like peeing twice
in the night i wasn't washing my hands
but still like my hands feel weird if i
don't wash them it's just like a mental
thing agree at the movie theater it's a
physical thing
okay well so that's very difficult to
yourself for sure um but it really made
me think about whiplash
yeah no i can't i honestly like i love
miles tyler so much like i just can't go
back down this road why because we
always talk about whiplash because you
know what he was really snubbed for an
oscar it's the most amazing movie like i
was just thinking about that while i was
taking my top gun piss and i was like
justice for miles teller oh 100 but it
also makes me think about footloose but
i do see that footloose is getting its
shine now because people are looking for
more miles teller content content and
there's literally
like hours of it in footloose that
movement started on tick tock they were
like girlies you're just waking up on
miles taylor now let me show you
something let me show you when he
learned how to dance let me show you
that two little girls that movie montage
of him it's the best movie montage ever
it really it's it's up there it's up
there with you know what else is really
good movie montage
the sweetest thing when they like lose
their clothes and they're trying on like
stuff oh yeah and she's like 27 28 with
her boobs yeah that's a good one there's
so many so many did they have one in top
gun i feel like the whole movie was a
montage honestly like it was just like
hot men
being hot oh yeah the movie montage that
everyone's obsessed with is them pink
playing football on the beach right and
it's
it lived up to the hype but i can assure
you that and say you want about tom
cruise like the man's body is
unique in a good way sorry tom cruise is
another one he's aging quite beautifully
yeah what do you mean i saw recent
pictures of him and he looks the same
yeah i know you can't say a nice thing
about him because you're very embroiled
in scientology and i'm not because i
have scruples
damn are you accusing me of being having
those scruples i'm not cruising accusing
you of being scrupulous i'm just saying
that's why i really can't no the the
difference is like you've watched all
the scientology shows and leo and like
you follow everything and i really
haven't so i'm sure if i got into it i'd
be singing a different tune and there
are also a lot of celebrities who are
scientologists who i don't feel like
boycotting but tom cruise is like the
number one and he's like a recruiter and
he's the face of it and he's the biggest
donor honestly it's like him and john
travolta but like i don't i feel like
you don't feel this way about john
travolta well because he was in
hairspray and that will absolve you of
all your sins it's just because you're
not a tom cruise girly in his body of
work
yeah that's for sure the truth but it's
also because he is the numero uno
yeah he's like number one donor he's
literally like the president he's like
the founder he's like that ron hubble
guy like whoever president of the
company literally
um so that's my that's cindy kenny with
the eyewitness news movie minute yeah
you should go on sandy canyon oh he
wouldn't be ready for me no he wouldn't
i'd be like shut up sandy
um also you read a lot this weekend we
both read the same book which was the
book for the redheads girls with bright
futures i did episode drops first
thursday of july but we are recording
this week so email your questions to the
redheadsbookclub gmail.com i'm so
excited that you read it because i was
reading and i was like claudia would
like this book it has all of the makings
of the claudius choice i have a couple
thoughts
the first thought is that if you've read
the book and have you ever seen dance
moms that annoying ass mom kelly is
literally kelly from dance moms like i
couldn't see it in your hollywood review
mention that on the podcast please okay
two i did really like it i've never read
a redhead book when it was the month i'm
always like a year late because that's
me like being so stubborn
i thought it was great a little too long
for my liking but still really really
good i liked a lot of the characters i
liked the story i liked the beat thank
you um and also i thought it was really
appropriate reading this weekend because
it was like not like a lot but like
abortion like it was like a part of it
so it just felt like relevant yes i
thought the same so i thought it was a
great weekend read and i really enjoyed
it i also read something else i just
cannot remember oh i read mrs harris
ghost paris and because when i went to
see top gun there was a trailer for this
super cute little like french film not
really but like cute little film and
they said based on the book and i was
like you know what i should tell jackie
to read this book because the movie is
so hurt like you would love it and then
i was like you don't let me read it and
it was like 150 pages why not me it was
150 pages that's why you read it yeah of
course um but then literally the second
i bought it on the first page it said
like the copyright it was literally
written in 1976 and i was like [ __ ]
book like i just feel like english is
different now like i wouldn't be able to
understand it it was
it was understandable but it was so
british like they kept calling her a
char woman
indeed what does that mean
literally i learned 50. i literally i
used the dictionary gorgeous after they
used it 50 times it means housekeeper
which i kind of assumed because the
whole premise of the book is like it's
this housekeeper who like cleans for
really like fancy ladies and she sees
one of the ladies has a dior dress and
she's
obsessed and she makes it her life's
mission to save enough money go to paris
and get herself a dress and then like
when she gets to paris it's this whole
wonderful adventure and everyone is so
like obsessed with mrs harris when they
meet her she's like a special woman i
that sounds amazing i know and then
there was a sequel mrs arrest goes to
paris and then mrs arrest goes to new
york and that one didn't rhyme so i was
like wait what's the sequel how is it
different from the first she goes to new
york no oh okay sorry
i thought you said the sequel was mrs
harris goes to paris no no mrs iris goes
to new york and then i was like
i've delved into like
yeah and i've delved into like enough
you know foreign literature for one day
okay
okay well thank you for that recap
gorgeous a lot of content from you this
weekend yeah no and that's what you get
when you don't drink oh and speaking of
drinking
jackie came in if you're wondering why
she's talking a mile a minute faster
than ever in my i think this ratio of
words spoken is 80 20.
no no you're doing great okay um so
jacqueline walked into the studio today
with not one but two travel mugs
mug
and she made me her signature coffee
that she started making at home like
only a couple weeks ago because she
thinks i would like it and i did have a
sip of it over the weekend and it was
good and she made me one and it's really
good you guys know i'm like very picky
about coffee so i'll just tell you
what's in it in case you guys are trying
to recreate at home drink along with
your girls it's really good this is
starbucks iced coffee from the bottle
with coffee mate hazelnut zero sugar and
stevia in the raw so good in the raw i
don't like regular stuff yeah you're a
raw girl you like it you like it wrong
so it's really good thank you jackie
that was very kind of you yeah i just
thought you know
why not her why not why this coffee yeah
i know that you liked it and i had i was
running late anyway so might as well
make two i was running light today too
you know what i did last night i took
melatonin
why because i'm just [ __ ] done with
not being able to sleep like i don't
think there's more hell on earth than
being up with your thoughts while your
[ __ ] husband is snoring like it's not
only are you like tortured by not being
able to sleep you're being taunted by
the sound of his snoring at how good
he's sleeping i hate being left with my
alone with my thoughts i can never turn
my brain off at night is when i like
turn into like worst case scenario
everyone i love dying my career ending
like it's so painful to be alone with
myself you know what they call those i
just learned this word intrusive
thoughts have you heard that yeah girly
welcome to the planet we know what
intrusive thoughts are
that's a new term yes it is but
intrusive thoughts are also like crazy
thoughts you have in your head like and
sometimes i do like i'll pick up
michaela and like i'm like should i
throw out the window but like you never
would you never would but it's like you
think your mind goes to the craziest
okay okay yeah i'm never gonna throw her
but it's like what if i just literally
throw the ball you know like yeah yeah
that's what an intrusive thought is it's
like a [ __ ] psychotic thing that
comes in your brain that you would never
act on but you're like why am i thinking
this okay i learned that on tick tock
and i'm like oh man sometimes i do i'm
like yeah yeah i'm on the plane i'm like
should i just run and scream bomb like
because like that's i don't know what
the cause is intrusion intrusion but
it's like these crazy outlandish things
in your brain although you would never
like agree with them or act on them they
pop up and you can't control it okay i
that makes a lot of sense yeah but
that's a relatively new term i hadn't
heard it until like a few months ago
because it's very intrusive thoughts are
very big in the postpartum world oh are
you having intrusive thoughts well i i
feel like i've always had intrusive
thoughts and then i saw other people
being like postpartum you know there's a
lot of anxiety have intrusive thoughts
and i thought enough times to realize
like bad thoughts that don't need to be
there yeah right but like you can't
control things that pop into your brain
they just do it yeah yeah yeah no
intrusive thoughts is a thing and i
definitely have them okay like wild ones
and i'm sure now if you didn't have them
you'll have them now because that's what
you get at the morning toast intrusive
thoughts
you're welcome um we also have dear uh
no not dear unburdened i'm burdening
yourselves today which is our monday
segment where you can write in and
unburden yourself with something
mortifying you did over the weekend and
we'll officially let that burden go for
you and we have some really funny ones
today so i'm excited to get into that
can't wait so i guess without further
ado let's get into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
today's episode is brought to you by
lollipop a new kind of soda that tastes
just like the sodas we grew up with but
unlike other sodas that are full of
sugar corn syrup and artificial
ingredients like aspartame oli pop is
made with natural ingredients that are
actually good for you so they have
delicious nostalgic flavors like vintage
cola classic root beer orange squeeze
cherry vanilla strawberry vanilla and
their newest flavor which is classic
grape obviously i'm a vintage cola girly
i also do love a cherry vanilla soda or
like a classic root beer because it
reminds me of like when we used to eat
it like like as a kid like old jewish
jellies like what was that place called
woodrow's oh yeah like with the rye
brown
yeah like it's so it's so lollipop you
know
so they use functional ingredients at
lollipop that combine the benefits of
prebiotics plant fiber and botanicals to
support your microbiome and benefit
digestive health so if you've been
looking for something like an
alternative to soda whether you want to
just cut back or stop drinking soda
altogether lollipop is really really
helpful because it tastes so good and
they're lower in sugar than conventional
sodas they only have two to five grams
and they come from natural sources so no
sugar is added their vintage cola has
two grams of sugar regular coca-cola has
39 grams of sugar
all the products non-gmo vegan paleo and
keto friendly so receive 20 off plus
free shipping on your order we recommend
trying the variety pack it's a great way
to taste all of their delicious flavors
go to drink olliepop.com toast or use
code toast at checkout to claim the deal
it's drink ollie pop
n k o l i p o p dot com slash toast
lollipop can also be found in over 8 000
stores across the country including
walmart target kroger whole foods
sprouts and publix today's episode is
also brought to you by bowling branch
bowlin branch uses the best 100 organic
cotton threads on earth for superior
softness and better night sleep their
sheets aren't just buttery and
breathable and impossibly soft to start
they get softer with every wash bowling
branch's signature sheets come in nine
neutral colors in all sizes from twin up
to california king that's what i have i
also have a lot of accessories have like
a bunch of throw blankets from that
blanket i also got zach i actually have
a little branch content coming too soon
but i got zach um the bullet marriage
robe for father's day and it was such a
good gift i never got a
robe from them yeah and it's a great
gift it is everything from bowling
branch is like premium the packaging is
stunning i've had the sheets for years i
haven't even replaced them i wash them
once a week and they get softer with
every wash they're super breathable i'm
a very warm sleeper and i find like when
i'm not using my bowling bridge i will
wake up with a moist neck and there's
really nothing worse than that no you'll
immediately feel the difference of their
iconic signature sheets they're 100 free
from toxins which means no pesticides
formaldehyde or other harsh chemicals
their sheets fit the deepest of
mattresses and are labeled with top and
bottom tags which is literally them
doing the world the lord's work because
if you've ever put on a fitted sheet
backwards and like your brow is sweaty
you know how horrible that is bowling
branch also is giving you a 30 night
risk free trial with free shipping and
returns on all orders get 15 off your
first set of sheets when you use promo
code toast at bowlin branch dot com
that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com code toast great okay our
first story
masked kanye west makes a surprise
appearance at the bet awards to honor
diddy so kanye put an end to his hiatus
with a surprise appearance at sunday's
2022 bet awards presenting sean diddy
combs with a lifetime achievement award
the rapper stunned the audience oh he
doesn't like when he's called the rapper
remember oh what does he like to be
called genius
yeah we're like rapper designer artist
yeah artist son thinker stunned the
audience when he walked on stage his
face completely covered by a hat
sunglasses and a mask after calling the
bad boys record creator a king he
described going to diddy for advice over
the years he said quote he inspires so
many of my choices so many of my life
choices my wife's choices thanks for
that puff
uh i guess technically it's still a
hiatus of like nobody saw his face you
know oh i guess so yeah he went on to
address his little hiatus saying i said
i just want to declare myself legally
dead for a year i just want to be off
the grid puff is pretty persistent but i
had to think bro it's like people get
amnesia so you know what i actually like
have a lot of respect for the fact that
he's like gonna take a whole year off i
think it would be really good for him
but he's like still you know
a good friend and like shows up for for
diddy i think he was getting like some
big lifetime achievement awards yes the
bet awards were last night there's like
a lot of news coming out jack harlow was
like wearing an outfit like in support
of lil nazax who has been like snubbed
for awards which is really weird oh i
didn't realize he was snub but i did see
his outfit and uh jucy sommelier was in
attendance at the bet awards which is so
weird
yeah and like confusing
so people were weirded out and confused
by that and i think whoever the host was
was making like comments about it i mean
it's literally like an elephant in the
room how could you not address that he
was there right
weirdness but um nice to see kanye out
and about i really hope he's doing well
like i totally
we were inundated with like kanye
content for something it always goes
that way and then we got like fatigued
by it and then i like kind of forgot
about him so i honestly i'm just really
wishing him well like
take a minute relax be with your family
focus on work and i really do love that
for him and i'm just always always
wanting the best for him but also like
support your friends of course you know
make sure to take time from your hiatus
to support your friends 100 which is
what he's doing so that's what he should
be doing yeah taking time and like i do
i honestly got really crazy and i think
people are like what's with the mess but
i kind of get it like
well i i like what you said you know
because he's still on if he we don't see
him is he still on his hiatus but even
before he went on hiatus like that was
his thing
fashion statement so i think it's a
fashion statement yeah i don't think it
has anything to do with what i said but
i like the artistic angle that you took
well i'm an artisan i like to make
[Laughter]
i'm constantly making
that's you i'm making it in my bed i'm
making it my pants i'm making my toilet
no
no
no i make where break you make on that
couch all day long all the time damn i
make on stage
you do
gotta come see me
okay ready for our next story yeah
because jessie james decker is opening
up about struggling with a cycle of
obsessive weight loss and also just a
mental health struggle in general so
jessie james decker posted on her
instagram on thursday talking about her
a cycle of obsessive weight fluctuation
she said quote i've been battling some
body image issues and when i really
think about it i probably always have i
go from one extreme to being obsessed
with working out and being muscular to
thin and just giving up and gaining
because the food makes me feel better
she also talked about how her mental
health has been suffering and sometimes
all she can do is break down and cry she
also talked about a reddit thread about
herself and her family that has really
hurt her it's not even so much a thread
as like a community that like literally
has a thousand posts like all the time
going about because she's like family
drama i mean who doesn't but like you
know they're all like mini influencers
so and i think her brother like talks
about it publicly a lot which is i think
feeding the beast
because she doesn't really address it
her her and her mom do not talk to
her brother and his wife yeah but they
are also influencers so people see like
all the things that they're not doing
together no and like i think i
definitely think like reddit culture has
gotten so out of control like
but that's like the point of reddit like
a free forum where everyone can talk
like great no but then why are only the
mean people there right like where are
the nice reddit forums right maybe
they're they're there but i've just
never been spoken about on them so i saw
her post i follow her and i was really
really surprised to see this because i
always just thought you know it's so
crazy how instagram is so not the truth
and to me like her life looks so charmed
i know especially on her reality show
like yeah and everybody loves her so
much and she's someone who like got
famous from her show and then became an
influencer and like just stayed famous
forever and like she now she has
kittenish and like she even did like
another show and she has like a
wonderful family and a wonderful husband
and you only see that but like you don't
see someone's internal struggles and
it's so easy to think oh she doesn't
care about the haters like look at all
the good but that's how much hate she
receives that like not only does it
affect her in her daily life but she's
gotten to a point where she actually is
now having to talk about it because it's
affecting her so much you know she's
like a rare breed of influencer
fused with celebrity like she's really a
traditional celebrity but like i think
she would make she makes her money as an
influencer
so she has like all the eyes of a
celebrity with like the toxic fandom of
an influencer and i think it's like and
i don't think i think she's probably one
of the most
talked about people on the internet for
that reason alone it's not even about
followers or level of fame she's just in
this unique place that like lends her to
have like one of the worst
audiences you know yeah and i always
just thought people loved her so much
because no i know them from the show but
it's been years that like she her reddit
it has a lot to do with her family drama
like it got people hooked and obsessed
and
she has been like one of the most talked
about reddit
thread like influencer deep dive that
people are obsessed with like for years
i know yeah yeah yeah also she talked
about how her career in country music is
you know another source of her
anxiety anxiety because she's not where
she wants to be and she feels like
she'll never be respected by the
industry because she's an influencer and
like why isn't her music taken seriously
okay i will say i don't necessarily
agree with that because i think country
music especially recently has like
really embraced like the especially on
tick tock like priscilla block is
literally a tick tocker who hosted like
the cma
red carpet i know you don't know her yet
but like i follow her and like she gets
so many opportunities all these new
country artists
have been discovered on tick tock i i
watch all their tick tocks they went to
cma fest and played at the spotify lab i
don't think
country music is anti-digital i think
they're anti-jesse jane stacker well i
think like a couple years ago she made a
stink that like the cmt or cma awards
did women in country but like carrie
underwood marin morris kelsey ballerini
and she made a whole stink on social
media about how she was excluded from it
and it's like you can't be excluded for
something you weren't eligible for yeah
so like i think there's been like a
sense of entitlement when it comes to
her music career and
i
i don't think she releases that much
music she does have a new song out
that's like extremely good she doesn't
release that much music but like her
music is very good and she's like she's
very talented so i really don't and
she's very famous and people want to go
to her shows and she like does her tours
and whatever like but just sort of like
operates in a vacuum and like why hasn't
she been embraced by country music it's
not because she's not not talented it
kind of gives the vibe when i watch her
music videos and whatever like that she
doesn't have a label like yeah like
she's doing it all independently and
that's what being an independent artist
is and i don't know for a fact if she
has a label or not but like she gives
the vibe of an independent artist yes
who has like a following but doesn't get
embraced by mainstream country or
mainstream pop or whatever the genre is
yeah so i don't know if what what like
the machine behind her is but it feels
like she has no machine right she's the
machine but i'm sure like the machine
gets tired and that's where she's coming
to with this post so it's like she's
opening up about her mental health
issues her body image issues and also
like that is something that people are
always talking about like how she looks
and her size which is so stupid because
like literally name someone more
stunning no but like even if she wasn't
like it's so twisted the way that people
talk about her i know really like
affects
it affects her behavior yeah so she's
just like coming clean with all of this
and saying like she's good for her she
said quote i feel like i only i try to
only post the good sometimes but i think
being open and honest will help me heal
through this i know i'm not alone and i
wanted you to know you're not alone too
i'm working through it and navigating
daily on how to heal because i'm sure
also the pressure to only post the good
just makes it bad you know more obvious
to her like all the things that she's
hiding so if she can just be honest now
and be like yes there's so much good but
also this is what i'm actually going
through i think we'll take a lot of
pressure off of her yeah i mean this has
been going on with her for years like i
remember like back in the breath days
like people were like sharing like her
reddit thread like it's exhausting and
it's also so
weird and i guess this is just like a
product of being a public persona but
it's one that i don't [ __ ] subscribe
to like people talking about your family
like it's literally disgusting yeah
and i just i think like reddit culture
has gotten so out of control in like
these sub communities where
people talk about
influencers is particularly damaging
because like first of all there's not
sub-communities where people talk about
like celebrities that deeply because
celebrities have afforded themselves a
level of privacy because they have so
much money and they don't have to go out
and work and make content every day they
can live off of their success for a year
and not post and not even be
forward-facing yeah so it's like
influencers have all like the negatives
of celebrity and really not as much of
the positives like you don't make nearly
as much money as an influencer
as an influencer you can afford
round-the-clock security but your
[ __ ] address is being posted on
reddit threads like it's actually really
[ __ ] up yeah like
so like being a celebrity is like
awesome and being an influencer is like
a thankless [ __ ] torturous job it
really is but also another element is
like people think it's the easiest job
in the world and like oh i think that
you make more money than you do no and
it's like they think like oh i can do
that and you know sit around in my house
all day like just post an ad and that's
the job yeah they think you don't
literally have to open up yourself to so
much so much scrutiny and like it's such
a battle and if there's like one or two
things in your life that you want to
keep private no no no [ __ ] we're gonna
write an article about it like it's loki
one of the worst [ __ ] jobs
um but i think people would say like
when you ask kids these days what they
want to be they want to be an influencer
no girl it's so taxing and like you have
to be active on social media and like
know what people are saying about you in
order to like efficiently do your job
where it's like if you're disliked as a
celebrity like you don't even have a
phone like if people do that for you
like you can disassociate from the
audience whereas an influencer you
cannot like yeah in order to effectively
keep doing your job and paying your
bills like you have to be in it and it's
so [ __ ] bad for your mental health
and you don't just you're not afforded
the same liberties and like respect and
privacy that traditional celebrities are
and traditional celebrities don't care
that like there's a page six oh look her
house and it has her address on it
because they literally live in like
gated communities with round-the-clock
surveillance and security guards for
their kids and celebrities influencers
don't have that yeah but like their
addresses are constantly being posted in
like facebook groups it's so [ __ ] up
yeah and like if you find yourself in a
position like sharing an influencer's
address i mean like this is public
information it's you need help like you
need to seriously get the [ __ ] off the
internet like if you want to find a way
to justify putting up someone's address
on a public forum especially if that
person has kids like you're sick you're
literally twisted and not okay and like
you need to seriously seek help yeah i
can't believe this is the way the
conversation's going but justice for
influencers justice for no i'm by the
way and there's like a huge
anti-influencer movement on
tick tock specifically
and it's just i i don't agree with it
what are the what are their points and
by the way there's like horrible
influencers for sure but there's
horrible people in every [ __ ] field
there's horrible accountants okay
so when did that become like accountants
are the worst you know right down with
accountants yeah and like this overall
just like hatred of influencers i think
is deeply rooted in jealousy for sure
because like to be an influencer you
have to be a successful influencer you
have to be like charismatic you have to
have something you have to be funny you
have to be interesting you have to be
beautiful like you have to be something
and as we've stated like you show the
highlight reel of your life so like you
a layperson just looks at that and it's
like their life is perfect and that
inspires jealousy but they also don't
see all the negative things right
because that's not the job no and then
if you do open yourself up to the hard
parts of the job you're ungrateful
you're complaining it's like oh okay
i'll go back to being miserable only
showing the highlights and being accused
of glorifying my life right it's
literally the worst job like and i feel
like you and i have definitely like had
private conversations about how like
we've definitely tried to like be
influencery less yeah more of like
podcaster comedian book club mom like
because the typical influencer like
swipe up swipe up and that's like your
whole life is so toxic and it's so
draining and like in order to be a
successful like content creator and like
your whole job is content on instagram
tic toc like you have to be extremely
strong which most people are not because
they're so young too they're getting
younger and younger right and like
you're just forced to like read these
horrible things about you and like
people you love and care about like it's
really [ __ ] up yeah
damn and you're damned if you do and
you're damned if you don't like i saw
i'm not gonna name because i i like her
she like was just people someone was
like why haven't you posted anything roe
v wade and she's like first of all shut
up
second of all like i literally have
that's the other thing like even with me
like i posted a couple things like the
second they expired so disappointed oh
yeah shut up like sorry you're not
active on social media like i've
literally posted throughout the weekend
they literally just expired give me a
[ __ ] break yeah give me one [ __ ]
second no but like
it's so it's so crazy like crazy that
people
absolutely need every single influencer
to post the same thing that like is
meaningless is it meaningless it's not
indicative of like real action or real
change and it's like i would feel better
knowing influencer follow did nothing
but called their local representative
and i didn't know about it right and
posting some fake ass canva pro graphic
like it's so disingenuous but we as a
culture we become obsessed with keeping
tally yeah okay this person must care
more than this person because they
posted three times but they only posted
once it's also weird how the mob only
cares about select things like and
ignores 99
of like other egregious things that
happen every single day but if you
didn't talk about these five things at
the disabled ex yeah the day we decided
you needed to talk about them it's like
what that's not how the world works it's
also just not how like discourse and
human beings work and i feel like when
you're in it you're like well of course
i have to post about it otherwise people
will think i think this yeah but i feel
like in the last year i've kind of like
taken a step back from instagram you
definitely have and now i see it and i'm
like this is you see it from the big
bang i see it from the big bang theory
and i'm like this is so crazy the way
that everybody feels this pressure and
this need to like post about just
certain things not it's not even about
like injustice necessarily because there
are so many injustices all the time and
like
they can have like hold this one i don't
want to like get specific but it's like
selective outrage select thank you yes
i agree and like if only the internet
like
whatever i'm not even gonna go down that
road all i was gonna say was the lesson
here is like just like chill the [ __ ]
out on your local influencer like
they're probably not doing okay and it's
probably because of you so like just
chill out this whole like like it's it's
like a joke now like influencer it's
like shut up first of all it doesn't
surprise me like influencer is like a 95
female dominated business we're
obviously just hating women because like
they're smart and successful in building
businesses for themselves and putting
their kids through school by your stupid
[ __ ] affiliate links shut up
and like to shut up period like shut up
if you find like yourself constantly
engaging in anti-influencer sentiment
like you're jealous and you're a loser
yeah and this is not me defending like
there's bad influencers for sure but
there's bad people everywhere so like
let's just not even do that totally i
don't know how we got here but the
lesson is justice for um
jessie james like yeah she's never hurt
anyone like leave her alone seriously
she's just a girl trying to be a singer
and as a fellow girl trying to be a
singer like i relate yeah like you
didn't get mainstream support for your
song it's disgusting and imagine if you
were putting out songs all the time and
like you really couldn't get and like
arrested it's number one on itunes like
why doesn't anyone care like this is
proof no it's true i will say i went
through like a
a stage in my life that i often forget
about where i was obsessed with jessie
and eric decker was during their show
like their wedding photo was my facebook
cover phone like when she sang to him at
their wedding like i thought that was
stunning now like people make fun of it
oh that's so mean people are so [ __ ]
mean i thought that was like the most
beautiful like it used to make me cry i
think um what is her like song like the
one that like when she was because when
she was she was a reality show but
before that she was think like
so good without you
i look so good without you no that's not
me a new hair dude does it feel oh
that's good yeah brand new since you
said that we've been through
you know that one and also i wear in my
blue jeans say in my blue jeans a wrap
no
i thought she was a country artist jeans
and it's also in the confessions of a
shopaholic movie what's like the one
like
hold on just give me a second i know
like nobody cares but just give me one
second because the one is i look so good
without you i really
i really believe
but oh the new one that she just came
out with that i see on tick tock is
really good should have known better
than a break my huh i mean she almost
came out with that
more
oh yeah only one be wanted by you yeah
it was getting like she was giving
jessica simpson like yeah no they're
very similar oh my she also has an old
town road version yeah i just saw that
okay we'll have to get into your catalog
later
um
but yeah like just back off of it back
off with everyone like everyone is just
doing their best like back off yeah and
if you ever like i just can't stress
this enough if you ever find yourself on
like a reddit
or like forum like bashing people like
you're not okay put the phone down put
the phone also go go for a run i feel
like i shouldn't
sorry like go have a snack
um i should say again like if you don't
like how people are using their platform
build your own it's so simple or just
like quietly disengaging but you can't
some people can't no it's not an airport
like your departure does not need to be
announced like just go damn i didn't
make that up that's like a common phrase
like i never heard of it so to me it's
like i thought it was spitting i thought
it was so poignant it's like this isn't
an airport you don't have to announce
your departure like we don't care leave
go go to sleep
you're crazy
this coffee is so good
i'm gonna bring you a coffee every day
now yeah or we could just like get it
here oh and actually we could because we
have a fridge and we don't need anything
we don't have an ice machine we should
get a crushed ice machine we should
prime day's coming up okay and it's like
it's expensive we should wait for it to
go on sale okay great idea
i would love that are you ready for our
next story which is some amazing news
that i think just you and i care about
which story is it number number three oh
wow okay yeah sorry jesse james like
took up all this time yeah
um just some positive news that i think
you and i care about hopefully some
other people do but lillian harrison is
pregnant expecting her first baby with
peter faucinelli right we didn't care
until the end um obsessed like obsessed
obsessed the fact that there's a woman
out there who is married to and carrying
the child of peter fuccinelli fills me
with rage jealousy but also joy that he
has found love in his life and he's
gonna be a dad and we're gonna have like
little facianellis running around it's
too much little [ __ ]
if you don't know who peter patricia is
um
what are you doing he educate yourself
educate yourself do better
he is the actor who plays carlisle um
cullen cullen oh my god thank you dr
carl dr cullen from twilight and he's
literally the hottest man alive and like
you wouldn't know it from his like
you know prosthetics and like hair and
makeup in twilight but he's so [ __ ]
hot
and i was listening on the twilight
podcast um like literally talking did
the episode come out it did we never
needed to listen to it because you told
us everything that happened on the show
obviously you didn't watch it um yeah of
the twilight effect it's called and they
were telling me like we love peter and
they're like pete and i was like what i
would do to like be on a nickname basis
with peter facinelli i mean technically
we are on a nickname basis with peter
facinelli because we call him lil fudge
but it's too and also i think our
obsession with him is just his last name
because like dr faceman dr facianelli
yeah also our obsession with him was
like finding out that dr carlisle cullen
is like the number one richest fictional
character according to forbes and then
he did like this strip down shoot in the
middle of covet talking about his
coveted weight loss and it was the
hottest thing i've ever seen for most
people like kobe didn't go that way and
you know went the other way and it was
really gorgeous and it just
reinvigorated plus we had been like
re-watching twilight and dr carlisle and
like with that scene in the last one
when i don't know edward is like don't
don't spoil it in case it's like that
and i always don't make this episode too
emotional yeah totally it is the biggest
twist oh no that's not what i was going
to say sorry not thank you for this life
you've given us yeah thank you for this
extraordinary life oh my god i'm
actually gonna cry i can't that's like
up there with paddington saying thanking
the queen it's also up there with
literally my favorite line in twilight
history his vows
right no amount of time
will ever be enough with you
but let's start with forever gorgeous
because they're literally vampires who
live forever but everyone else is like
oh
forever
so cute also we're just obsessed with
twilight so like that's where the
obsession you don't have to justify why
we want to talk about no but we do have
like like hundreds of thousands of new
listeners here from tick tock i don't
know if they didn't make it through the
first part of this episode maybe they're
still not here but um i just feel like i
feel the need to explain myself yeah and
also i think like peter faucinelli and
dr cullen is a character
that the older you get the more you
appreciate like i don't even think i
really registered him when i first saw
twilight at the age of like 18. of
course but now it's like a grown woman i
recognize and respect the businessman
beau that's the part of growing up is
realizing you know the older characters
in your favorite things actually were
where it was at 100
and then like even like i'm sure if i
went back and watched like sleepover
when i was a kid i'm like
jane lynch is so annoying and i'm like
actually no she's [ __ ] right you guys
are literally 12 years old stay the [ __ ]
in your room stay home and yeah she
needs a night out at the club with her
girly yeah no and it's like oh you're
gonna go to a club and drive around you
guys are literally 14. right why do you
why should you be in the club but she
shouldn't right and it's like when i was
a kid i'm like oh my god oh her mom's in
a club and now i'm like yeah mom get it
a hundred percent that's growing up and
like get you a man who spends all night
fixing the water filtration system and
installing some fresh water that's some
of his best work yeah
that was so good
evan peters it's all about perspective
yeah life is about perspective i would
say yeah and if you just look at
everything from the lens of the big bang
theory nothing matters and that's
take such a wait it's freeing yeah
yeah
are you ready for our next story which
is some exciting athletic news is it the
exciting athletic news that's brought to
you by modern fertility yes what if i
told you you could get important
fertility insight without going to the
doctor or even leaving home that's why
modern fertility was created it's an
easy and affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick you mail it in with a
prepaid label and you'll get all your
personalized results within 10 days so
you'll get insights into your hormone
levels your ovarian reserve and tons of
other important fertility factors the
results go deep into what every hormone
means and you can also talk one-on-one
with a fertility nurse to review your
results and options
traditional testing with your doctor can
cost over a thousand dollars but modern
fertility gets you the same information
at 159
and we have a code for you guys if you
use code toast you get 20 off so that's
139
if you have an hsa or an fsa you can put
those dollars towards modern fertility
and right now modern fertility is
offering our listeners 20 off the test
when you go to modernfertility.com
toast that means your test will cost 139
instead of the hundreds of thousands you
could cost at a doctor's office get 20
off your fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com
toastmodernfertility.com
toast thank you our exciting athletic
news the next generation of lakers are
here the lakers have signed scottie
pippen and shaq's sons scottie pippen jr
and sharif o'neill obsessed with success
the l.a lakers have signed sharif o'neil
and scottie pippen jr to two-way
contracts with the team sharif is the
son of shaq whose jersey was retired by
the la organization in 2013 he will play
for the purple and gold during next
summer next month's summer league and
larsa pippen son also known as scottie
pippen son will also play for uh the
lakers as well lars supposed to
instagram about the exciting news for
scottie pippen jr kim kardashian
commented huge huge
huge let me say how obsessed with this i
am because like i love like a like a
father-son like i do love a nepotistic
moment but also like in the nba like you
can't just really get on a team for
being someone something you have to also
be extremely talented and so i like that
they're starting in the summer league
starting at the bottom so it's like
they're really going to earn their spots
while also being like legacy players
i just i love everything about this
story especially the kim of it all yeah
and that they're playing together and
they're playing for like their dad's
teams and that like
scottie pippen oh wait he was chicago
yeah and then i think miami no or he
just lived there
yeah yeah so he's not a laker girly no
okay cool but the lakers are very cool
team
totally premium very obviously like kind
of the most premium yeah i mean i don't
think everyone like not from a
basketball perspective but more from
like a branding perspective and now they
play at the crypto stadium it's less
cool it was much cooler when it was a
staples center yeah no but like what
would you say is the coolest basketball
team
if you could go anywhere
as a player yeah like lakers yes but i
think it's different for everyone like i
think
like as a player the dream would be like
to play forever in your hometown like
where your family is like not have to
pick up and move every year you know
yeah no but for some players like they
want to go to la they want to go to
miami they want to come to new york no
they don't want to come to new york they
can't get on the knicks oh my god me and
ben were not interested to the movies
and this guy walked past us like kind of
cutie and ben was like looking at me i'm
like yeah it's hot right
and that's like no that's i had no idea
but like a new player on the knicks and
like ben ben was like shook i'm like
come let's go like let me just i'm sure
he gets it all the time like let's just
he was literally right behind us i'm
like let's just go take a picture he was
like no and he just stood there and
stared at him for 15 minutes oh my god
what if ben had spoken to him he would
have used his charms and ben would be on
the starting five of the knicks
literally or at least like courtside
seats like ben would have showed him
that three-pointer he scored at the
charity tournament ben never gets like
shook shook or like starstruck and he's
always the one being like claudia just
go like go talk to this person and i was
so surprised to see him like actually
like quaking i'm like just go like
first of all he's in new york he was
literally standing outside
bloomingdale's like tourists he probably
gets it 55 times a day like who cares go
then you have gotten a picture for life
that was like no no no like stopping
such a weenie
ben would have had a friend for life if
he just went and said hi that's the
benefit the benefit
anyways this is very cute and sweet it
is and kim's commenting on lars's things
this is good news for kim larson
relations what do we think this means
and it actually kind of validates what
larso was saying like we're not not
friends but we're just like not as close
as we were like this is what you do for
someone who you're not super close with
like who maybe like had a milestone on
instagram and you like [ __ ] and you like
write muzzle or like right right but you
don't do that for your sworn enemy no
and but for your best best friend you're
like oh my god i knew this day would
come i've been holding this in forever
and we know they're not best best
friends anymore but they're not sworn
enemies they're not not speaking and as
lara so like always said like our kids
are friends and like this just proves
that like
they are in decent terms and larson
wasn't lying on real housewives
no i agree and i'm really happy for her
like yeah you could tell her kids are
like her greatest joy in life yeah
i think everyone's but like you know
what i mean yeah yeah very very cool
news cool athletic news our fifth and
final story is something so crazy and i
absolutely need to get your thoughts on
it okay amazon has revealed that alexa
could soon imitate voices of people's
dead loved ones
amazon is experimenting with a new
feature that will allow its alexa voice
assistant to mimic the voice of other
people including the voices of people
who have died
the vice rohit prasad the vice president
and head scientist for alexa artificial
intelligence spoke about the
relationship between consumers and their
virtual assistants during amazon's mars
conference in
las vegas on wednesday
one thing that surprised me the most
about alexa is the companionship
relationship we have with it in this
companionship role human attributes of
empathy and effect are key to building
trust these attributes have become even
more important during these times of the
ongoing pandemic when so many of us have
lost somebody we love
then they showed a video of a boy asking
alexa to read a bedtime story using his
grandmother's voice in the example alexa
registered the request and switched to
the grandmother's voice before reading
the story as you saw in this experience
instead of alex's voice reading the book
it's the kid's grandma's voice while ai
can't eliminate that pain of loss it can
definitely make their memories last
i don't have like a visceral reaction
yet i think we need to like talk it
through a little bit before i decide
where i land because part of me is like
oh that's cool like when it's grandma
reading a bedtime story like how could
you you know hate it hate that and it
makes me think of like the hologram
kanye did and like how overwhelmed the
girls were um
so part of me is like yeah but then part
of me is like this [ __ ] weird and
like you know certain things in life are
guaranteed death and grief is one of
those things and so
to circumvent well here's the thing i
think the idea that you know if if
someone had like a recording of grandma
saying reading their favorite book and
they could play it to their grandkid
like that's really nice but i think the
idea that the artificial intelligence is
mimicking human beings and then also
like talking about ai being like
empathetic i'm good like alexa just tell
me the [ __ ] weather no i agree like
i'm leaning towards like this being
weird just because it's like ai doesn't
need to be so up in our business yeah
and like i don't know there's something
weird about manufactured like emotion
you know it's not going to stop at
bedtime stories no and like the con the
example they gave is like the perfect
example sweet but like that's not what i
would be using it for like
i i don't know it just [ __ ] weirds me
out and i can't really explain why it
weirds me out i don't have a rhyme or a
reason i just think it's [ __ ] weird
yeah i just think a.i like doesn't need
to be your grandmother yeah and like
i don't know like missing your
grandmother is part of the human
condition you know do you have gran's
consent to use her voice and likeness
100
grand's gonna see you from the grave
yeah it's just like twisted like let
gran rest yeah i don't know she's read
enough bedtime stories she's exhausted
it just weirds me out and like
i don't really see the benefit aside
from this little one example right they
must have thought for hours about the
best perfect because i can't argue with
that of course but it's just his
grandmother but i still think the
concept is [ __ ] she's here in spirit
it's creepy yeah
and honestly like obviously i lost my
dad at a young age i haven't heard his
voice in literally
14 years
i don't think i want alexa to show it to
me right and it's like
grief is very you know finite yeah and
to add these layers of grief where it's
like okay you're not here and i miss you
but i can still hear your voice and like
you're speaking to me but alexa's
writing it but she's going based on your
personality because she's ai and she has
empathy now it's like this is too
confusing just let the man rest yeah i
do
see why they thought this was a good
idea because i know a lot of people like
will call the voicemail of a loved one
to hear their voice
um and you know actually this is so
weird the other day
i have this app that's literally the
best app ever and i'm not telling you
the name because like i don't want
people to know my secret um that you can
plug in a phone number and they'll
literally tell you who it belongs to so
i plugged in our dad's cell phone number
and like it's been reassigned
oh isn't that sad yeah but it's a good
number so i know
like i was thinking of calling it like
just being like what's up that would be
easy but then i checked first and like
wasn't registered to
michael autry damn yeah so i'm sad but
um i don't think i'll be using the
service and i'm okay thank you amazon's
like already like a little too literally
my doorbell rings do you use alexa do
you have one yeah i have um the one with
the screen i think it's it's not an echo
it's a oh yeah yeah yeah edge but that
one doesn't talk she does oh she does
play games with her um i use it it's in
my bathroom and i play music when i
shower but it also tracks my amazon so
literally
my doorbell ring
and i could tell like based on the
doorbell ring if i need to get up for it
everything or if i don't do you know
what i mean because also a sticky order
something that was supposed to be
imminent like no like
i can hear the service
door open and close so like when the
doorbell rings and the service door
closed i know they just dropped off a
package and i don't have to get up but
if i don't hear that door i know they're
waiting and of course i'm gonna go get
up but literally they dropped the
package doorbell rings and then alexa's
like your amazon delivery has been
delivered
it was [ __ ] creepy like but that also
shows very good building efficiency yeah
so i just feel like amazon's like really
up my ass like i don't think i need them
in my grief you know yeah i think i'm
gonna try to need them in the grave yeah
and you know me like i will sell my soul
to amazon just to get something slightly
more conveniently this i'm not into yeah
no
a hair too far so those were the best
five stories and i definitely feel as
though you needed to know every single
one of them yeah and now we're gonna
dive into unburden yourselves which is
our uh advice segment every monday you
can write us on burden yourselves
gmail.com we'll keep it anonymous when
you tell us something embarrassing you
did that's like weighing on you you know
worse and we just try to help you work
through it and let it go
so unburden yourselves is brought to you
by the green pet shop if you're like us
and you talk about your pets as if
they're human beings hashtag larp summer
is officially here and the risks of heat
stroke in our pets is hot humid weather
i'm sorry i'm starting again i bought
this okay but make sure to include
hashtag larp again if you're like us and
you talk about your pets as if they're
human beings hashtag larping and you
treat them as your children listen up
summer's officially here and the risk of
heat stroke in our pets in hot humid
weather is treacherous and terrifying so
the green pet shops patented and
award-winning cool pet pad is a
self-activated gel it's a gel cooling
mat that keeps your pet cool for hours
it's pressure activated so once your dog
or cat lays on the pad they start
feeling the cooling effects instantly
plus these mats are eco-friendly they
have no water no refrigeration and no
electricity needed you just grab it and
go so my mother-in-law's always sending
me like little articles like to be aware
of theo's um paw pads on the hot
concrete in the city um and she's
totally right it's like a thing people
don't think about because obviously you
maybe put your dogs in shoes during the
winter but it's just as dangerous in the
summer and especially with us going away
for this weekend the dogs are gonna be
spending so much time outside and we
just leave them outside and they lay and
it's so much better for the dogs like
water we give them ice cubes but there's
more that you can be doing especially
for their feet
you can add a fashion flare to your
order with a pink or a gray cover for
your cooling mat and a pack of pouy
viton eco-waste bags hui vuitton are the
thickest strongest and most stylist eco
waste bags on the market they're made
from cornstarch instead of plastic and
you and your dog are doing your part to
protect the planet pui vuton the number
one bag for number two
to shop the cool pet pad and the poi
vuitton eco waste bags use code toast
for 20 off at thegreenpetshop.com
that's code toast at thegreenpetshop.com
actually i have the previous time so
bruce like won't [ __ ] in anything else i
believe he's like he's not designer not
interested i believe this is a toaster
owned brand because at my chicago meet
and greet they gave me like a lifetime
supply of pooey vuton bags love that all
right ready to unburden yes hey jackson
claude hi i need to unburden myself big
time i'm a nurse practitioner and work
with some really sweet older adults i
see on a weekly basis i recently had a
baby and of course when i came back to
work after maternity leave all my
patients wanted me to show them pictures
of my precious new baby i was showing a
sweet older man some recent photos
and was swiping through and accidentally
swiped to an up-close breastfeeding
photo oh forgive yourself my entire boob
was out and i immediately snatched my
phone away but i know he saw i turned
bright red and just stuttered and left
the room i'm mortified how can i ever
face this man again sincerely a girl who
never is going to show a picture of
herself at work again okay like you need
to forgive yourself because if you're a
breastfeeding mama like you realize that
a tit isn't even like a sexual organ
it's just a thing that makes milk and
there's like nothing weird about it yeah
like you're just
showing like your stove
literally like you showed a picture of
your fridge
it's literally a fridge
no and the benefit i guess of you
working with older people like they're
not immature like booby like if they're
old they maybe had kids like they saw
their wife breastfeed like they're more
mature i don't think this is a big deal
at all yeah like as you have so much
more on your plate and you're a nurse
like you know bodies like it's really
not a big deal just forgive yourself
move on i'm sure this man old man is
understanding
i thought it was going to be you know
like a penis me too something but like
no you probably like had to send a
picture to your doctor like
you can't worry about this no and nor
should you also another benefit of
working with the senile is that they're
so forgetful so tomorrow won't be an
issue so you can officially let it go
yeah
next up hey claudia and jackie thanks
for always keeping me laughing now let
me end my burden i have two adorable
dogs one is large furry breed and the
other is a small terrier mix the big dog
was at the groomer and i was going to
pick him up i always bring the small dog
along with me i'm standing in the lobby
with my small dog waiting for them to
bring the bigger dog out and for context
i work as a veterinarian and i'm in my
scrubs i just came from work so i'm used
to dog stuff and i'm used to like gross
stuff i'm the only one in the lobby as
the only girl at the desk went to go get
my dog i look down at my small dog and
there's a poop nugget next to him my
small dog had pooped in the lobby and
i'm immediately embarrassed i don't even
think i bent down to grab the nugget
bare-handed and i put it in my pocket i
look around for a trash can and there is
none in sight why i'm standing there
with poop in my pocket the lady comes
back out with my bigger dog and i leave
i get to my car reach in my pocket and
pull out the poop and throw it in the
grass how disgusting i hope that place
doesn't have cameras sincerely a
dedicated and embarrassed dog mom i mean
that's so dedicated of you and so
unnecessary like if this is a dog
grooming place they clearly have the
mechanisms to pick up dog poop your dog
is not the only dog who took a massive
dump in this lobby and you should be
grateful it wasn't your big dog it was a
tiny little cute little it was a small
rocks poo it was a small rocks it was
clearly rocks because you it was still
intact after being in your pocket like
some of bryce's poops like they turned
to mush i just feel like you went out of
your way to be like overly gracious and
embarrassed but honestly it's a dog
grooming place like i'm sure that's even
worse they express anal glands yeah like
you really didn't need to do that and
that it makes you look like a really
nice you know
i would want you as a customer in my
business like you're extremely gracious
but you really didn't have to be
yeah
or like there literally wasn't a tissue
anywhere but a poop bag like it's a dog
place yeah i understand if you were in
you know the metropolitan museum of art
or like a target you know it's not nice
to like same thing no like if you're a
target like
and your dog takes a [ __ ] like you can't
just leave like you have to no but like
or something but like and i feel like at
target they have mechanisms where you
could clean up a mess yeah clean up some
make sure maybe at the met they didn't
and like you're you know
had to pick it up with your hand sure i
just think like you went above and
beyond when you really didn't need to i
agree but and you shouldn't be
embarrassed at all because like do you
forgive yourself because like the only
person you hurt was yourself yeah which
is amazing when it comes to unburdening
yourselves because you can forgive
yourself you're not in control of other
people yeah
this third and final one is so funny
okay
to my two favorite sisters and king
charles cavalier dog moms bryson
i absolutely love your show i look
forward to it every day and you bring me
such joy
last week i was in a busy starbucks in
downtown boston getting a midday
pick-me-up i saw this adorable king
charles cavalier and beeline to it of
course brass and strassen relatable i
started talking to the owner and knelt
down and the dog jumped on my knees in
the vicinity of my crotch i immediately
said i bet he smells my kitty cat
she kind of looked at me weird but i
didn't think anything of it i walked
away and realized this woman doesn't
know i have a real life cat that i'm
obsessed with and she might have thought
i was referring referring to my vagina
yeah i couldn't stop laughing and now i
can't stop thinking about it it would
have been better if i just said cat of
course but i said kitty cat like a
lunatic if she knew how obsessed i was
with my cat it would have made more
sense of course anyway xoxo your loyal
fan and fellow pet mom enthusiast that's
just really fun unfortunate and the good
thing about it being an interaction with
a stranger is like you literally will
never see this person again there's no
need to be embarrassed and at least you
learn this lesson like with a stranger
you're not you know someone when you
work with or anything where you need to
clear things up but that is so
hysterical
and you know because you basically
you're basically like oh my buddy smells
like [ __ ]
because that's also a word for cat right
and i think
we live in a culture that's really sick
and twisted like you can't say kitty cat
without thinking of vagina and we need
to all like understand the world we live
in
the dog was like going for her vagina
right
the dog was like smelling her arm like
licking her arms no but if the dog was
going for her vagina and she said oh we
must smell my cat like no one would have
thought anything of it like this is the
lesson here you have to take a lesson
away from every situation where you have
to unburden yourself and the lesson is
you will never refer to your cat as a
kitty cat ever again yeah do you think
if she said oh i me he probably smells
like kitty
oh no no because kitty's also a vagina
just with the parallel between cats and
vaginas how every word for cat
can be also used for vagina what's the
connection i don't know
kitty kitty cat [ __ ] pussycat
you gotta say my feline so there's no
confusion yeah my domesticated pet
named laurel or whatever your dog says
it sounds like your vagina
yeah that sounds like your vagina i
would like love an explanation on the
parallels between names for your vagina
names for your cat i don't know if i'm
missing it but like drop it in the
comments
yeah
like why is that
maybe it's just because like the of the
puss of it all like there's just like
crossover
so then everything else crosses over i
don't know no i really don't know but i
never really thought long and hard about
it but now that i am i'm perplexed
positively perplexed
um thank you to everyone who was very
vulnerable with us um we hope this was a
safe space for you thank you to bryson
strassen for being amazing members of
the community and thank you to you
jackie for being my sister oh my god and
my biggest confidant
and supporter
and thank you for you for always
supporting me as well you know it means
a lot to be seen and heard by you
and i just
love you very much oh i love you too
that's a great way to end the show
tomorrow oh let's talk about the week
for a little bit yeah do we even have
our week ironed out yeah we are going to
be here today obviously tomorrow and
wednesday thursday's 50 50. either it's
going to be clear we're still working on
our plans we're still working out it's
either going to be podcast only or
in studio we will have an episode
thursday
okay do you not agree i don't know
there's one case scenario where we might
not no no there's literally no case
scenario where we not we literally have
ads but homie like we have to okay we'll
talk about it offline but sure there's
no show friday and there's no show
monday for july 4th weekend so i just
want you to like go into your week
knowing what you have coming but the
good news is is that there is breaking
bread this week and there's patreon
episodes as always we're actually
recording such a fun one next right
after this so if you are feeling rdh
about our absence this weekend like
there's so much content for you and we
will let you know where it is and where
you can get it so don't even worry don't
sweat it and tomorrow we're interviewing
jill zarin yes talking real housewives
ultimate
with breakfast
breaking bread with rose and joseph so
that's our show thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the pasta store is that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so
if you are watching this on youtube yes
please where we get serious don't feel
free no just [ __ ] do it okay
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
you know what the thumbs up is optional
the subscribe button is not it's
mandatory if you enjoy this video more
targeted yeah please subscribe we're
also available as a podcast and where
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
video cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
enclave day and we'll see you tomorrow
bye crayon make it nothing lesson in
crab
bye